all right we're looking at coku
Hall uh Jesse had a question on it so I
I did recently do a video on the kazushi
pattern that you always use for the uh
back uh outward kazushi pattern okay um
but there's just a huge misunderstanding
on kho so we'll do it again but I
recommend watching that video and I'll
post a link to that video again in the
comment section of this post
po um let's look at the common way of
doing this technique the common way of
doing this technique generates a
yongyong clash energetically so that
means it's not going to function
alchemically and it is not going to
function spiritually then does it
function martially and I would say if
you're bigger and stronger than that
person then it'll function but to set
out with a technique that requires you
to be bigger and stronger than your
opponent I don't think that's martially
viable that's the that would be the
definition of not Marshal viable like
you know hey come do our art it works on
everybody who's smaller and weaker than
you that that's and every
aikidoka should start seeing it for
okay so in the modern iido that
means in everyone else's iido but mine
that's a a way you can understand it
uh and the
founders uh UK would be let's say this
we're going to have a sign here okay and
this is n sign and we just want to
look at some
forces
okay in the kold waza UK has forward
inertia and momentum going this way
towards noget
okay if we
stop that energy in any way right there
and then you're going to have a young
young Clash cuz they're coming this way
and if you they're going da and you go
stop
here Clash you have to let their energy
go forward if we and often is the case
for example in I
you you have UK stop there
and a lot of people do
this UK stops at the
line such that there's no Clash at
contact well then you have no spinal
displacement and then the Marshal sense
for this technique is not there it's
just not there and so it would not
function martially again we're only
dealing with the Marshall question
because we already it's not going to
work spiritually and it's not going to
work energetically it's the Marshal
question so for anyone who does not have
spinal displacement stops themselves at
the ukan Naga meeting
point such that I'm not actually
clashing with them then I don't have
spinal displacement and now I have no
Marshall sense for not one of aikido's
kona so if you try to do this technique
on somebody who is stopped you're in the
street or in a sparring you're not going
to get what you think you're going to
get they're going to beat the out
of you okay so this is this is wrong too
from a marshall point of view so we
can't have Uka stop and we cannot stop
UK that's the first thing okay so get
let's do it let's do on film and I'll
show you what I'm talking
about okay so I
and I'm going to come in I have an
forward
inertia and that inertia is going to do
spinal displacement so he's not he's
going to stop me okay he's clashing with
me right now he's sto he's going against
my forward inertia because he stopped me
my inertia was going
forward if I have more masks I can
generate more mask which I will be able
to do cuz I'm going to incorporate the
earth into my mass and that's going to
be more mass than him I will override
The yyong Clash so he come in and he's
not going to be able to stop me
okay the example of me stopping myself
he offers his hand is me auk I take that
forward inertia momentum and then I stop
right here that is what a lot of people
do okay and so as
he uh would come forward he has to come
forward to me do you see he does
that what happens in in a fight is as he
starts to take my balance here and I
feel that pressure there go
back I just adapt to it and I keep my
same base you see I just adapt to it I
feel the pressure on the hand starting
to check my weight so I would let go of
your control point I still have my base
and then this gives me different things
that I can
do there will be no time where you'll be
able to get there in any kind of Marshal
situation so for example here I am
standing straight up I don't have any
forward inertia acting on my Center
gravity and any kind of uh assault I
don't care what what he does go he has
no control over me so he can't get it to
go okay
this is all Marshal
so we are not going to stop UK
and we're not going to do anything that
stops UK and when we say stop UK we're
really talking about their center of
gravity we don't we want the center of
gravity to keep going
forward usually what happens is here's
ukia
spine there's our head
and this is bodies moving
forward and what the modern noget does
is they create a break
here and then they bring the top of the
spine down and forward see
that so when this UK gets over here
they're going to look
for this
position and and here it is
true the head came forward of that line
but the center did not and that's what
we that's what's
determining uh whether we y Yang Clash
or not okay why is that because most of
the Yang energy is in the center of
gravity because that's where the most
inertia is the most Mass the most weight
Etc and so when you do bring the head
forward you actually stop the center
from coming forward and now you still
have a young young Clash okay and I'll
show you why you stop the center from
coming forward what's going to happen is
when you bring the head down you're
going to inhibit the center to come
forward because the feet will get
pinned this energy that is going down in
this
direction is biomechanic
going to pin the feet in
place
biomechanically and hence the center
cannot come forward we often use this
strategy uh in
infighting when we want to make sure
that the person can't kick us or knee us
we'll pull the head down forward and it
pins the feet in place I'll show you
that now all right so if we're here
we're fighting and I don't want him to
KNE
me I can come up and pull his head down
and now in this
angle this L shape
here with especially with weight on it
his feet are inhibited from coming up
off the ground and getting that knees
hence if we're in the front and there's
no forward inertia you do want to make
sure the head is towards you down so you
can check those leg
weapons inversely while we're here if if
we're in the
back and there's no forward inertia and
this has a lot to do with where we
ultimately go we want it the other way
meaning uh if I was here his feet can
move back they can okay uh they just
can't go
forward if I'm here his feet can go go
forward and kick but you can't kick
backwards okay so whenever for example
we're arresting someone we're going to
separate his
feet more turn his toes
outward place his hands behind his
back and we're back
here having weight on the heels and even
this is enough to protect him from
kicking at us
okay versus like in the movies where you
see hey put your hands on the wall
separate your
feet right FIS this guy he can kick me
all he wants at that point
okay so if we Bend his head forward
consequentially you're going to stop
that forward
inertia you're going to stop that by
checking his feet he's not going to come
forward anymore and if you pay attention
the center gets stuck in place and this
is why the UK who do this he didn't get
over here they have to enter they have
to close they have to move towards him
okay that's the second point we're
showing okay continuing with the
modern stupidity
what the modern
ioka
assumes is something like
this uh they're going to make this
two-dimensional circular
action okay so the the movement of their
tabaki is going to uh use this part here
this part on the circumference this is
where we stop UK If there's a y energy
going that that way it then takes them
down okay and that's where we bend them
over at their at their head and stop
their keep their Center stop and then
it's going to come all the way around
and here's where we're going to take
this head and bring it back to
here we come up to this Apex here okay
and then it's going to continue around
and start bringing them sorry this is
where we think we brought it back up
okay and then it's going to take them
back and this is where we're doing that
part okay this is what they're imagining
and because this arm movement is in
their mind continuous and circular they
think that's iido but as we saw here at
this point we we have the Yong Yong
Clash okay we come down and we're simply
uh out Ying here meaning you're
continuing this
mindset I'm going to get you down uh
with leverage keep your center from not
moving okay but now you have inertia
here the inertia is at this point and
what did you do you picked it you're
trying to pick it back up against its
static inertia that's another y Yong
Clash when you pass through this phase
up here this upright phase at this
point you've regain you've given them
back their balance here you had some
sort of check on their balance but now
you brought them back up to the balance
state so you did something then you
undid something and there's no kazushi
here NK no kazushi sui and again you
have the inertia that is upright in a
state of
balance and then you have your other Y
young Clash over here as you bend them
backwards more into this position so
even though you have this continuous
Circle uh it's just wrong it's wrong
everywhere why is it wrong because it
has a Yong Yong Clash again we already
noted Yong Yong clashes have no
spiritual effect they're all OT
tripartite mind uh there's no alchemical
effect from it uh it's all going to be
external engines and things like that
but martially I have to be stronger than
this person every step of the way and
that in itself makes it not Marshal okay
how does it function then like I've seen
it function well you haven't seen it
function in a sparring situation that's
for sure okay you seen it
functioning in a cultural
choreography where the UK will in no
way keep the Y Yong clashing so what the
UK will do is at this
point they will reduce their inertia
through
choreography to be able to come up and
at this point then they'll come up and
then at this point they'll reduce ruce
their uh Yong Yong energy they'll reduce
the yangong energy Again by reducing
their inertia by going backwards with it
and this all has the guys that uh well
that's iido you're not supposed to fight
and struggle do you see um the
difference here is that the UK is
consciously reducing
inertia that's
different I am not supposed to as UK
contest and struggle yes because it's a
form but what makes it choreography is
that I have
artificially uh generated inertia levels
that's that we don't do you don't do
that okay you keep the inertia levels
that you have and that's it's up to
nogin to figure out how to work with
these given inertia levels okay
so here is a a
clear scientific way of understanding
what is choreography falsified inertial
levels okay that's what it is what is
it's not it's not compliance because in
all kho and waza you're going to have
you what I mean is it's not it's not the
uh lack of struggling is not the lack of
contestation because in all kihon you
don't have struggle you don't have non-c
contestation but what you don't do in
true kihon is artificially
generate pseudo inertia levels that you
don't do that okay um that's wrong so
let's
demonstrate uh these falsified inertia
levels okay and I'm going to have to
coach my my uh Desi into this because
they just don't know this okay we
don't do this stuff so
I'll get us there first a lot of times
like I look probably bigger and stronger
than I might actually be on the video
but I am a tiny man he's not even that
big a man you're like a normalized man I
would say right and the guy is
freaking like I'm like a baby okay
um so I'm not I'm not like if I were
your
size everything I'm about to show would
be even more detrimental if I was bigger
than you it would be even more
detrimental okay so
um here he is we already know even
though I'm not as big as him because I
know how to
ground hold me still with all whatever
skills you want I don't care even if you
brace If You Want To Bra why don't you
take the brace you one like brace brace
okay like we're don't let me get you you
see that so even though he's doing that
I can still push this
guy okay now
imagine 200 I weigh what do you weigh I
weigh 220 okay if I was over 200 lb like
that it's easy peasy okay you
know what I'm talking about um all right
so here we are we don't want to Yong
Yong Clash there let me say this too
it's not just a matter of strength okay
so let let's say he's he's bracing again
okay he's bracing like that my goal
marshy is not to just push you right so
as as we're going here and you're
defending yourself right and I would
come
in and
get get
two jaw two button Palm heel strikes and
a groin kick and now the big man is not
the same big man as before do you get
what I'm saying so it's not enough just
to stop the effects of the Yong Yong
Clash because you can over out y me
there's ways that it's just not right to
do you want to keep the inertia moving
okay all right
so um I'm going to stop the clashing
here or maybe I have it and then you try
to bend me straight down with that that
arm Circle do you get it okay so here I
am like that okay so again I'm I am
pushing
and this is just leveraged you
see okay and it it didn't go so smooth
right so your I people are going hey
increase your mass step a little so this
hand is under your Center you see that
okay so here we
go it's still not that smooth is it did
he get it
yes I weigh a lot less than you and I
have no thumbs and that's what he's
doing so this is without thumbs he
goes you see and then again I'm checked
and I'm stopped but get my off
balance no I have all my legs again
still
okay so we're seeing the weaknesses of
the Yong Yong clashing what usually
happens is I reduce my
inertia you see that difference right
here's where you see me doing this go
you got to go really slow okay
one I'm going to start putting my butt
out I know where you want me to go go
and I make my butt go out go back and
you will feel let's reverse it I won't
make my butt go out I make you bend my
head over you're going to feel a lot of
the inertia of me standing go right
there you see how it's increasing
there's a lot of pressure here not going
down as he goes you're going to feel
that you can overpower it but you still
feel the pressure right yes and it goes
off when my butt goes out and I bend you
see how it's off yes
okay watch what the UK does you're going
to not feel the pressure you
see I take my butt
out there's no pressure you see that
while stay where you are put my butt
back in pressure you see okay so the Uka
is reducing the inertia in by first
making their butt go backwards and when
their butt goes backwards they now stop
their forward progress this technique
makes no more sense okay and then the
second thing they'll do is they'll
either let out the pressure at the grip
like that so here I am watch go slow I'm
going to make my butt go out to take
that grip pressure off okay if I stay
here and you continue you'll feel
there's the grip pressure increasing you
see that so what they'll do is they go
like that the pressure is not on there
do you see that and so you always see
this in the in all all the UK okay or
I'll step so I'll keep my grip there
goes my
butt and then I stepped underneath you
you see that that means I'm in control
of my center and that's why for example
you don't really have me I have to stay
there okay and I staying there I'm
changing the inertial values okay so
here we go again boom boom
boom all right now we have the next one
he brought me down let's say he's over
able to overpower me he brought me down
okay and he's going to continue to make
that Circle this is what he's picturing
he's making that Circle okay at some
point he steps with that Circle well
when you go back he steps there it is
like that so we'll demonstrate it get my
dishy in the right what do you think
what we're trying to so he goes here he
goes up and then he goes
down okay but as I said there's the Y
Yong clashes let's say we're here
okay he's got to bring me up
now he's trying to bring me forward on
that Circle no he's not going to ever do
it he brought me down okay but I have to
now change the inertial values do I do
that to see how I'm doing that okay and
it all goes under well you got you're
not supposed to contest you're supposed
to go away but what I'm doing is
changing the inertial values okay
again we're here I'll change it I took
those little baby steps forward for him
okay and now as you see at a certain
point I'm just here in perfect balance
of course in the fight this is where all
this stuff happens
right all this stuff
happens you can't take balance then give
it back never makes sense we're back
where we were here I am right now in
perfect balance and now you have the
inertia of that plus the mobility you
afforded me so for example let's say he
is able to overpower me and he can't
make me go
back what at this point stops me from
stepping regaining the balance you see
the UK changes the inertial
value by doing
this you have no capacity no matter what
I'm holding on to you have no capacity
to stop me from doing that okay on a big
strong person
we get there there we are now you have
to put that you got to do their okay
here we
are okay and on her and on her big
strong
person she is not going to even get me
to have to step so as she's
going okay it's not ever going to happen
I have to change the inertial values
by doing
this
okay if we look from a top view okay top
view this
is UK
Center and UK's
head as the UK comes
forward they stay over each other in
kazushi you see and they're going to hit
the NOG
line when they hit the NOG line there's
UK Center we're looking down from the
top and here's UK's
head
okay that's the con the the initial
kazushi okay let's do another time
frame here's the n
line as Naga is making this
two-dimensional
Circle the
head comes back
up over that
position so this is what I'm trying to
say here you see that we call
balance here it looks exactly the same
and modern aikidoka call it kazushi it's
not kition okay it's actually balance
okay
then as they're continuing the
Circle H his heads over here and they
fall
down if you watch this
pattern from the top down and you plot
it I go this
way and I have a straight
line now I go this
way and I still have a straight line so
even though I have a
circle the overall posture of UK is
linear and my technique my tactical
geometry is linear I'm just going like
this do you see and the fact that I went
for forward and then
back is where you again have that YY
Clash that bouchain could not overpower
at that point okay at the top at the top
of the of the
circle okay and you can see I clashed
with them when I stopped here and now
I'm clashing with them when I'm trying
to make them go back from there okay
that's so then again this is not
functions spiritually because it does
not function alchemically and this does
not function martially because it will
only function on someone that you're
bigger than right and we know from the
art that the art is not linear this
circle this two-dimensional circle is
the self- delusion that we are not being
linear but you actually are being linear
okay what we want instead is to actually
do what the art says we want to have a
spiral
geometry we don't want to have energy
going back on itself because energy that
stops or energy that reverses is going
to generate a yongyong clash with the
inertia at that given contact point it's
just what it does okay so
UK's uh center of gravity we'll just
look at that is going to go
forward past the nogget line
that's going to be spinal displacement
which gives Marshall sense to the
technique and we're not going to stop it
there we're going to turn it on a circle
cuz we cannot turn it back on
itself it's going to go on a
circle like
this and then like
this
okay if you pay
attention this is why this is called
coku
hole same with the coku is
but all of my techniques do this for the
for the most part all of my kihon do
this thing which means I'm going to
spiral
rotate in One Direction fulfilling
half of the Genesis act and then I'm
going to spiral rotate on the other
direction completing the other half so
all the Keon waza is an alchemical
energetic purification ritual consisting
of the the recreation The Act of
Creation you do a another Act of
Creation according to Silk Road culture
what is the Act of
Creation uh the the let's just use the
Chinese
uh Triune you have a dow that's prior to
all dichotomy it manifests in
dichotomy uh and then and so to reverse
this I start with dichotomy and I
reverse it back to this pre- dichotomous
State okay and in order to do this I
have to spiral rotate Yin and yangong
you can if I only spiral rotate in One
Direction I still have dichotomy so I
have to spiral rotate in the other
direction as you can
see you have continuous motion which and
continuous ongoing whatever you know
whatever it is and this is our infinity
symbol across the globe today okay and
so you could see it here okay um this is
what ukis Center is
doing it's not what I'm doing though I
cannot achieve this shape of their
inertia uh by painting this physically
okay so for
example at this point in this turn do
you
see I am
still I am not moving
okay at this point in this turn
and I'm on the inside of UK's inertia at
this point of this
turn I am on the
outside so I'm on the inside of this
curve here
okay at this point in the
turn my
I'm over
here I have to move to do this so as the
as this shape is going around you see
what I am doing I am constantly on the
inside of the circumference whatever
circumference I'm making I'm constantly
on the inside and here for example I
will be on the
inside with two feet side by
side on this one I will have two feet
side by side
where you have your your Yin half of the
universe I'm in she anti she's anai
she's zai and when I get over here I'm
in
kamay so again half of the Universe I
have shisen no stance do you see that no
stance is a way to think about it uh and
so I'm in the yin
phase they're going around me it's kind
of a Ura variation they're going around
me at this point and this is feminine
and at this point I have a stance Comm I
have EDI do you see and my feet are
apart and I'm on the other side of the
creation act and this is masculine and
this is water and this is fire and now
you've completed this act that we've
done okay at no no point in any of this
pattern do I make a UK Center here and
their head over here on a
two-dimensional plane okay what I do
instead is they turn like
this it doesn't break in half because
when you break it in half and you have
this L
shape the center stops moving the feet
get pinned and and it won't work okay
what I'm going to do instead is they're
going to go this way the head's going to
turn this way allowing the center to
keep going forward the head's going to
be brought
around back this
way and then it's going to go this way
okay and this does something very
important and this is where I want to
focus on because as we get to the
tabaki we have to make sure
that the outside foot does not is not
plantable in Con in contest with the
ultimate falling geometry and I'll show
you what I mean there okay so again
they're moving this way tilt the head
this way allow the feet to keep going
bring the head around now the feet are
forward do you see that then I bring the
head this way
and it's too late they don't have a foot
on the back and they're going to fall
okay we in in my art and uh I think if
you were a sociologist I would do the
following
okay
um start tracking when my earliest
videos were for kho and you I've take
I've always taking out the leg it goes
back to my Kempo training you always you
always work both sides of the circle so
you always take out the leg I've always
taken out the leg on coku hole for my UK
that can do it but it's getting popular
now and everyone's taking out the leg
it's popular because they're watching my
videos because it's not but they're
doing it wrong they don't quite
understand it okay um and that is more
indicative of you watch the video
without understanding it and you haven't
entirely let go of the modern IID DOA
geometry okay uh all right so I'm going
to show you what we're trying to solve
martially with this problem we're going
to solve all those no need for inertia
uh modification by UK and we're going to
make sure that they can actually
fall all right so as I did it with Bou
when she got me
here because I'm here and he goes to
push me if I did not want to bend in the
waist changing the inertia value as
again now
choreograph I could very well as any
fighter would would move away from the
force acting on their body and regain a
structural Integrity so this foot is now
movable okay that's the part that when I
did my move here for the throw there or
I did my move here to come in right that
foot was relevant to it so we don't want
UK to have control of that
foot so we want to preoccupy the foot
with the forward progress okay so we'll
start with katate I know your question
was on monot but when we go to monot we
have to ensure that we understand this
concept okay so right here in this
progression I'm going to show you that
pattern and we'll get to that foot okay
so he's got spinal
displacement on I don't contest I go
with it you see I make him go around me
but he's tilting do you see like the
marker was I step inside the arc that
I'm going to make we already know this
is now qua and my goal martially is to
get rid of the grip in terms of it it's
not I don't pull the hand like in that
other technique I'm looking for his head
to come and touch my shoulder ug could
let go all he wants but because of the
inertia going forward the centrifical
energy and his contrast to cental energy
plus my internal skills I can manipulate
him here okay and he's starting to go
around and that is what we
want we walk that foot preoccupied with
the forward
inertia we're going really slow when you
go faster everything gets easier and
better okay so I don't contest here I go
around I step inside the arc that I'm
going to make I tilt his body I get his
head and I get that foot going
forward room
inside that's what we're trying to do
here he will a good your good athlete is
going to at some point get that foot
back you see and offer I have inertia
here again if that ever happen I don't
try to bend him or throw him you have to
go to something else that then that
technique didn't work cuz you jacked it
up but this is why in the technique
we're going to try to go slow but before
he gets that foot back I'm in and
attacking the other leg so
you do see some UK when I go slow and
light they get it there but they're not
they're not here nor here they're like
toe and the other leg is being buckled
okay and then the throw is still viable
okay okay now let's get into your
question about uh katate versus m okay
so if you pay
attention you can come closer to this
and you can stand up so you can see
okay
B is a combination of
Kate and II kador
okay what is doing
alchemically is it's increased the
katate weight okay in this technique
so he has so much
mass he has more mass okay but what I'm
doing is exactly the
same the second hand only becomes a
problem when I'm trying to overpower you
you see so for example don't let me do
that crazy okay
so okay cool
again not martially functional cuz
nothing travels at that slow pace okay
now due to his size I'm not going to he
can you can offer way more resistance do
you see I can't even I can't step there
due to that his ability uh his physical
ability so it's not Marshall okay but
here as he comes in do you see I don't
contest there and I don't try to do any
kind of joint locks on you okay so
instead I turn this so what do I mean
let's look at
katate I don't try to use open your
fingers I don't try to use my forearm
bone as a leverage on that thumb joint
I'm not trying to do that stay there
please stay there I'm not trying to do
this and that's what happens pretend I
can do it that's what you're doing here
you see
it's still an external Force engine of
Leverage if my lever and my for my
leverage engine is not able to do the
work capacity to overcome your
resistance and it's not going to work
okay what I'm doing instead is turning
inside his grip I don't go against the
joints and you can see that that starts
to
tilt and that doesn't change whether he
has the other hand on
it I'm not going to pull this hand
I'm going to go inside the
grips okay and when I go inside the
grips I'm using my quaw so it's not my
arm my quaw is doing
it and I'm taking it between his legs
where he has no base into the sh into
the
shikaku not into the Lead
Foot
here and it blends with his
inertia forward inertia comes in thank
you don't
contest and then the pattern is exactly
the same
I never had to bend his body so I don't
need to overpower his grip strength the
pattern is exactly the same he doesn't
get his foot in the back so the kadori
grip never gains power okay uh it
doesn't change a single thing
it
K with the grid the COA hand will only
cause problems in the other one again
assume I can do this part when you get
here if you pay attention katata D
you're fine is on the other side so he
can't really stop me I mean he probably
could cuz he can pull me more than I
could here okay but the other hand
is engaged on the back foot do you see
the kosa hand is now able to add to
whatever that back foot could have done
on his body so now you made that hand
push push able you g gave it and so why
is it a problem it's in a problem in the
modern aikidoka pattern but katatori was
a problem in the modern aikidoka problem
too in my version the other hand is irr
other hand does not matter okay I don't
feel it okay which is part of the
training if you're doing the pattern
right you should not feel the other hand
if you're not doing the pattern right
you have a Yong Yong Clash into the
throat and you're going to feel the
other hand so Mori to me is a training
tool test for are you Yong Yong in that
Clash or not
okay so uh as I posted that last video
on
khole um you know some people thought it
was indicative of this Shihan and you
know some other people rightly pointed
out no it's totally different as you can
see it's totally different okay one one
one has one has this shape and one has
this
shape this is totally different okay
[Music]
um you know you go oh well there's a arm
Circle all right that is your
shape it's not this okay and
likewise as I've always said there's not
a direct one to
one um
application between kho and waza and a
and a marshall um utilization okay the
figure the the the utilization is at the
conceptual level and the conceptual
level uses this
shape this this is this is the symbol
for what today we call jiujitsu but this
is the symbol for non-c
contestation that's the symbol for non-c
contestation this this is not the symbol
for non-c contestation this is not the
symbol for non-contest station either
okay um and you use this
pattern so I think it was in the knife
video for
example I I described it as teni net
Chon so they had me in the Russian tie
on the 211
in my hand that way my arm to stop
themselves from being stabbed and I did
the same pattern on the uh inside of my
body Koko does it on the outside of my
body but I do the same pattern on the
inside of my body do you see it's the
exact same move there's only one move in
iido it's this it's just that because in
if you define iido as kihon waza there's
only one move in the application of
kihon waza is that
okay because this is non-c contestation
because this is the uh Genesis and
Regenesis act that that's what you do
that's all you have okay and it
works
um here's though what what deceives
US is as the UK comes in in the modern
iido which is every single she
that's alive today or that died after o
Sensei so all the lineage okay all that
lineage
too again they're doing this
shape
okay
is again looking at the there's the top
view of the head and the top view of the
spine then it hits the nogget line
here's the top view of the
head I'm sorry of the spine and then
here's the top view of the head they get
that L shape they bend them over you see
and then we know eventually they're
going to bring them up and then they're
going to bring them down like that okay
So eventually this comes back here the
head comes back over and then the head
goes behind the spine they're now going
backwards so let's let's look at that
point right there okay so we're now
two-dimensional here's the lower part of
the body
and here's the upper part of the body
going
backwards and Naga is now going this way
on that 180 Clash you're going to
throw at this
point head
[Music]
feet your big
male Naga you see whoever it is and I I
don't I don't think it
has to be even that big a person at this
point is going to
do this part of the
circle and gets the downward pressure on
that
Circle and you that person is going to
go boom and you as the UK with your
egocentric orientation of the world is
going to go that really felt powerful to
me and therefore is powerful
see well there's a couple things
though it's not that you can't Yong Yong
this you can you can Yong Yong that
because the the Yang potential in this
body structure is so
low that relatively anyone can overpower
this and then a bigger person can really
really overpower it and give you the
subjective sense of power of objective
power what the modern aikidoka who goes
that is a good koku hole that my teacher
could really kill you on that technique
do you get it and then they afford them
the Marshal practicality of their
iido is that everything that it took to
get to this
shape was all choreograph was all the UK
changing the inertia
values that means everything that it
took to get to this point in that
technique where you
felt a delusionally derived objective
power because it's a subjective
power everything that it took to get
there will never ever ever ever happen
in a
fight so the fact that you felt some
power there that you
diluted portrayed as objective power
does not make it Marshal because
everything that it took to get there
will never ever in a million years
happen in a fight and it will never ever
be uh
conceptually uh transferred into another
shape there's just absolutely no way
this will function and that is why I say
that version is not not Marshall and
this is also why you modern
aikidoka you will struggle with every
single UK who will not make those
inertial adjustments for you until you
get them here so your senior Senpai
who's like a big fat who can't bend
his back they're going to teach you
about the tabaki at the grip because
they can't even get there
do you see that or your UK who
who you threaten in the pecking order of
your social hierarchy and the dojo like
man you're training so much you're
really catching up to me uh they're
going to fight you at every one of those
YY clashes do you see that and then
you'll see them go with your teacher who
out ranks them and they'll get their ass
there just fine do you see that and
because it's all choreography
it's not real okay it's also why you see
the um the um Shan when they demonstrate
this and when they show their power the
the conventional line is well I can't
hurt uh my beginner who doesn't know how
to fall like that what's actually
happening is the beginner doesn't know
the inertial adjustments to make that's
why they're a bad UK and uh they never
get there for that Shan or you never get
your beginner students into into that
position okay so versus like when you
see me with all the different UK levels
and we have some pretty dramatic UK
levels in the dojo um they're going to
go off balance that other foot is going
to come forward it's going to be taken
from them the only thing I leave off is
for safety reasons I don't take out the
the supported leg on the Lesser skill
duas but brand new people everybody is
going to go into that shape which is
telling you how applicable that shape is
for people who are going to contesting
and move and countering and things like
that because we don't need them to
adjust inertial levels to satisfy the YY
clashes that are in this this thing this
thing okay